[Applause]
i actually wish that you would come out
to the west wing theme i think that
would have been
hilarious can we have them see i want to
see gene simmons come out to the west
wing thing
let's see that again a more stately gene
simmons
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so much to talk about yeah so little
time so little time that's a nice
looking book
isn't it nice wow
new york times best seller here you
[ __ ]
that's all i can say we'll get to the
book in a minute but first let's give
the people what they want the famous
gene simmons tongue
no no no no no no
[Music]
you ready
[Applause]
you just ruined the west wing theme
forever
hi max you know what uh honestly uh no
joke
that's a great band that's the greatest
band in late night
let me um because we have limited time
and there's so much to talk about let me
ask you quickly
um first of all you wore the makeup then
there was a period
in the 80s when you didn't wear the
makeup right then you started wearing
the makeup again right was there ever a
transitional period where you wore
half makeup did that never happened you
never thought about it would you ever
think about that
pay me okay i'll pay you do your kids
understand
do you have i have so many questions to
get to do your children
you have kids they have to know of yeah
what a wonderful line for the ladies i
mean it's true i mean you have two kids
you said do your kids know what you do
oh yeah my uh my boy is now 13 years old
my
my daughter's about nine going on ten
and of course uh on the day in school
when everybody said what does your mom
and dad do for a living and so on and so
forth they came in as little dentists
and little hairdressers and so on
and my kid came in with a six-foot
poster which he sort of unrolled
and there i am drooling blood and
spitting fires that's that's
my dad but i bet he's proud though oh
yeah we've got kiss comic books kiss
cell phones
kiss everything you know like all the
cool stuff that kids have so if you're
gonna go
home never leave home without it babe
because the kiss visa card is right
there you can have it
yeah hey god i'm looking good too look
at that
is there nothing you won't do
you've really got a kiss cell phone is
it like any other cell phone but it just
has the little members of the band on it
well the difference is you have to buy
it and then i get paid
[Applause]
nice pitch you've got there for the
price i i think you've got something
that makes me want to have one
you brought something backstage which i
find hard to believe i understand it's
backstage right now we're going to wheel
this out
good idea all right let's take this is
actually for sale it's a kiss
coffin
um you got to see the top it's really
cool
can you see the back oh no that's the
same as the front by the way
this is available at kissonline.com or
at your local funeral house
and by the way if you're watching this
is a real one and if you're watching the
ball game
you don't have to wait to die for me to
get a buck really
you can actually reach in there and grab
a cold one because it's actually a
cooler
you know by the way tomorrow even as we
sit here
what made you decide that the world
needed a kiss coffin
i mean what made you think i've got it
kiss coffin are there people that want a
kiss confidence
yes actually seriously has anyone bought
has one been sold
thousands not true sports
you know what you know what get on
online there's white light casket
company
they produce it for us sports bars i
know it's being sold but has anyone
bought one has there been
one tons literally they're in sports
bars you know guys want to
you know they're watching the ball game
and everything else is cooler but
there's no one who wants to go into the
hereafter right but no one really wants
to go into the hair after in a kiss
coffin
why not
[Laughter]
it's that logic
i can't argue with that logic why not
all right this
this blew my mind this is really
available
you're selling these people look at this
ladies and gentlemen
it's a kiss checkbook now that's what
i'm talking about yeah
bye now by the way just making it as if
i wrote someone a check on a kid's
checkbook
and tried to buy something like over a
thousand dollars
don't you think i'd get some but
wouldn't i be in danger that people
think it would be a gag it's like
that money that has the moose on it
president no no no no this is currency
recognized around the world
if it says kiss on it don't worry it's
legit
by the way just make it out to gene
simmons
oh but it's like working with an animal
don't get too close
i have to thank everybody you know from
my heart
i was born in israel which you'll find
out when you buy kiss and makeup
uh i'm gonna be at the virgin mega store
tomorrow at 6 00 p.m
in times square come and see me but the
most important thing is thank you all
thank you so much for making kiss the
number one american group
gold record winners of all time our box
set just went gold
we now beat every other american band
thank you so much i love you
[Applause]
well i uh thank you for being here gene
there's two things at the bottom i'm
supposed to plug but you just did that
for me i did i actually think you did it
12 times during the segment
uh all right that's uh that's our
infomercial for the evening
gene simmons everybody we'll take a
break
you